uh
i'd like to talk about uh
some incorrections in my opinion
i i see in in the
aikido tip the teachers doing weapons
you know
anyone like that i said on
one of my films i i see people doing
strange things and i
and i really don't understand why they
do it and it's all to do with posture
i watch oh senses posture tomorrow
senses
tuber senses knee show senses
toei sensei um
sugana scentsy you know sadly these
wonderful wonderful masters are no
longer here
yamada sense is the only one that i know
of here and
and tada sensei tarda sensei
oh he's i don't know if he's in his 80s
late 80s now and he's still teaching
and he's uh got a wonderful dynamic
about him
so if you do get chance to be lucky
enough to
see tyler sensei or your mother sensei
please please do so
now these two teachers are not
what i call iwama style
they don't like the way through the
school of iwama
it's now been run by the maina aikikai
and it's been
done up superbly and it's a very
beautiful
area now much more than when i went
there to train
i admire these teachers because they
they all have wonderful aikido
it all works i remember watching
the other day noro scentsy he was in
paris
he could jump in roman aggie behind
somebody's neck
as if a cat jumped from a floor onto a
two meter high wall you know these
masters not to be seen anymore
all we see now is
aikido done performed
nothing much turns me on when i see it
and with a wow
and sadly that means that i've not
really got any wow in me either
but i'm still hoping still hoping that
there'll be some thing that i can pass
on
i get so much out of my own training
and i love seeing other people enjoying
their self when i'm teaching
when i go to russia it's wonderful so
many people are still
so enthusiastic but the world is
declining in numbers
and as you can see i'm no youngster and
i'm more than likely to talk to you
who's
not a youngster either i would like to
think that
i could turn the tide
but you need to be looking for something
as a person
we have to do something in life with our
time on this earth
and i've enjoyed doing it through arts
tai chi
you know aikido meditation healing
anyhow i'd like to talk about what i
don't see and all those masters i've
told you about
and yet a lot of these new
um teachers
are showing it and i don't know where
they've got it from i've no idea
where they got it from i decided to go
against the
the norm and not to do
what they taught in iwama with the ken
i decided to go
another route am i right am i wrong i
don't know but for me i am correct for
myself
now a teacher said to me many many years
ago
why would you step onto a spare and of
course
nobody would would they
so when when you see people
here or you know they're back here
now anyone who would talk to step first
to give you grounding and then cut
lift up step first
cut to me
this teacher had
my attention he said
there's something from a film before
watch my elbows they're not out here
they have to be the width of my
shoulders
because if my shoulders are to go
through a door space or
space of that size so that's my arms
i can't get through a door if my arms
are white so here
so you learn to tap them in but you
still see through them
and it warmer they were taught to step
get good grounding
cut i disagreed when he said
we were doing a part in the practice and
i went like that
and he skied me firmly in the chest
he said why would you walk onto a spear
of course it was a bokken but i took his
meaning as yes
who would be in their right mind to
to do that before they had their weapon
to defend their self
like the the traditional western
thinking you wouldn't go out in the rain
without an umbrella
or you wouldn't go out in the rain with
an umbrella
and open it after you were wet but not
if you've got a brain in here
so i decided from that day on
uh i think i was a second down then i
decided on that day on
to
to bring the sword down
followed through with the leg and then
end the cut together so
from here if you can see the feet
i open on the ball of the foot
open the ball foot as it comes through
the ball of the foot lands and it goes
down with the heel as i cut
so i'd like you to just consider that
use your everyday mind not the
martial art things that you're told why
would you walk onto a spear
yes it will make you more stable and you
can create more mass
but watch saito senses films
when he's cutting and you'll notice even
when he's doing the suburbs the moment
he starts
to have some motion he doesn't step
first and then cut he does it together
so use your eyes
hey hey
you you learn maths
by doing taranucci cutting the tar
this is you use a much bigger ken than
this you use a saburi bokken
it's a burrito saburi bokken it's a much
bigger one
you hold it with two hands together like
this
not with a space and you
you strike the tar you strike the tar
the ken or the saburi
it jumps about two inches from the tar
and you stop it with your stomach
by doing this with your stomach
you stop it about two inches from
the bounce of the tire you do not keep
it on the tire
if it does if it does a a little bounce
like that it's
incorrect it means you haven't used your
power and turned in
to stop it all right so it's done with
the breath just a
quick flash and then you breathe
normally
okay the can those of you are lucky
enough to have a talent should tell
you the can
cut straight if it does this
and it bounces to the right or bounces
to the left it's also incorrect
it should hit the tower and just
come up straight and stop about five
centimeters seven centimeters from the
tire
okay hey hey
hi this is taro nuchi this will teach
you how to
build mass the other exercise i was
telling you
is about um cutting
now what i see is when we cut
the baby's got a little bend it can
it mustn't be locked as long as it's got
a little bit of softness
then it's okay okay it needs a little
bit of softness
but i'm seeing this from me while my
teachers now
i don't know where they've got it from
but but as they do the whole thing
as they cut they sit back like this
as if they're sitting on a bathtub i
know i mentioned this before
this is completely wrong
i've also said on one of the films
cytosensei saw me doing this
many years ago in germany and said you
look like a duck tony what are you doing
sticking your butt out like that you
won't see him do it like this
okay if it's got any bend at all it's
there
but the progression of the body is
forward the progression of the body is
forward
it's not sitting back if you sit
back aikido has come to a stop
and they say that i could almost never
stop it must always be able to flow into
another move
even when you've thrown somebody you
know the throw
should lead you into another move
if you sit if you end your cut
like this hey
hey you know
i'm stuck here now i can't move quickly
it defeats so be careful because if
aikido is full of contradictions but if
they're good contradictions
it's worth it it means that you m
your mind cannot settle because there's
a contradiction
you have to think about something else
and think about something else
they're good contradictions
but if you can tell me where you see
any of these great masters
hey if you can see any of these red
masters
doing it like this
please show me the film because i only
see it in the modern
people of today and not the great
masters
of yesteryear okay
i've had my workout i hope you've
enjoyed it
if you don't have uh space i'm lucky in
my hallway here
i had the space to be able to do ken and
joe and i hope
to tell you some more things these
things have been with me forever
you know many many years and on seminars
i share them
and i'm a stickler for detail
because with detail you will become
precise
but you will also find your normal
everyday human being
can blend with your martial artist side
and not be over the top about trying to
look like someone else
when you shouldn't be trying at all the
techniques i've taught you
she and aggie watching the hands always
seeing the hand always seeing the hands
always
in the hands always seeing the hands
these are things that will make your
aikido
more secure whatever style you're doing
you all do sheer naggies you all do
color guys
you all do it yours if you want to make
them more secure
and not to feel as if oh dear i didn't
really get that one right
or um i trained with somebody new on a
seminar and they stopped me doing the
technique
you know if you want this not to happen
and you want to about train
and execute every single technique with
everybody you meet
then you need detail you need position
you don't need to step onto a sphere
use your common sense thank you for
watching
and i hope that um one day we'll perhaps
meet